I am going to play for you something
quite stunning and this goes to you know
we've talked before on the program about
the pseudo-intellectual and
anti-intellectual movement and this has
come overwhelmingly from the American
right wing although sometimes the left
engages in it as well and one of the
things that has been a staple one of the
aspects to this that has been a stable
from the right
is that thinking too much actually isn't
that good formal education is little
more than liberal indoctrination and so
we shouldn't even really be praising or
seeking out intellectualism but there's
another aspect to this which is making
nonsense people out to be
intellectuals that they are not and I
have an example of this that is quite
stunning uh Tucker Carlson introduced an
interview that he did with I guess
former actor and now YouTuber Russell
Brand Tucker Carlson refers to Russell
Bland Russell Brand as a public
intellectual now I know I know that will
come as a shock to many of you
but what is stunning is that then
Russell Brand proceeds to rant
completely unintelligibly about kovid
for five minutes and Tucker just sits
there looking dazed take a look at this
there there is a lot that I want to talk
about from this clip let's listen so as
we told you we sat down yesterday with
Russell Brand the comedian actor and now
frankly kind of a public intellectual
for about an hour and a half on our show
Tucker Carlson today we want to share
more of it tonight in particular Brands
spent a lot of time thinking about and
telling us about the thinking lockdowns
yeah and the point Russell has thought
about it a lot of them was maybe the
clearest explanation we have heard of
what we've just lived through here it is
[Music]
all right
I think kovid provided a lens through
which we could scrutinize the Machinery
of power and how the intentions and
agenda of Power are able to play out
coalesce and let's call it conspire when
a crisis occurs now remember there's two
things here that might trick right
Wingers into thinking that this is deep
thought one is that for the American
audience you know where I'm going
Russell Brand speaks with a British
accent and that actually is quite an
effective tool this this applies both to
left and right I hate to say it into
making it sound like someone is actually
speaking quite intelligently the other
thing is that he is only feeding back to
a lot of the these right Wingers the
things they already believe our
attendancy a globalist tendency to
increase surveillance a big Tech
appetite to capture data and a
comparable appetite within government
converges the Great American comedian
George Carlin used to say there is no
need for conspiracy where in address
converge it seems that even if at its
Advent it was a legitimate crisis and I
certainly wouldn't make any contention
around that it was opportunistically
handled in order to enhance regulation
and control at a time where regulation
and control are increasingly difficult
to implement as people are more
suspicious of institutional power so in
a sense the best way to understand covid
I believe is to take covid out of it and
look at how the institutions both ignore
covid to understand covet and government
behaved around it pretend almost like
there was no covet and then be like well
none of this stuff made sense if you
remove covert from it right well but
there was covet how did they benefit how
did they utilize it what narratives did
they uh disseminate and which narrative
did they control and curtail even with
the recent text messages from our health
minister at that time Matt Hancock you
can explicitly see it was exploited oh
no we need to scare people is there any
way high net worth individuals can get
into the country all these conversations
but many people that are cynical about
the behavior of the powerful believed
were happening were indeed happening the
way that natural immunity was discussed
proved to be true I.E their natural
immunity is effective they probably
understood earlier than they admitted
that natural immunity was effective and
for reasons that what no the use of the
word probably what could it be and what
could be the reason that a monetizable
solution to covid was prioritized over a
non-manetizable is there anyone involved
in the situation well one interesting
aspect to that would be the dramatically
higher death rate of people who got
covered rather than unvaccinated versus
people who got coveted vaccinated that
would be one interesting reason why you
would prioritize the vaccination program
that has a profit motive let's look at
the data you know so what it was just
revelatory like the apocalypse always
will and remember Tucker Carlson hasn't
said a word we're two minutes in hey the
apocalypse is revelation of all what was
always there corruption convergence of
interests alliances this is not
conspiratorial the moot recital of
economic interests and the ordinary
movements of the powerful if people can
uh honor one another and talk to one
another in good faith and recognize that
anybody if they're like there's a whole
debater between like that I've sort of
felt a little bit around me even for
coming here I feel like it used to just
be normal that someone in your family
would be a conservative and someone in
your family would be liberal and someone
in your family would be socialist and
someone in your family would be trans
and someone in your family would be gay
and different races are coming together
is this part of who we are and if it
isn't the part of who we are it's
certainly okay so this goes on and on
and on and on and on okay so a couple
different things here first of all most
of the things that Russell is saying
actually just aren't true and if you
really kind of dissect all of this
different stuff you see there's really
nothing there but I want to zoom out and
talk about this this the framing that
Tucker Carlson gave of saying that
Russell Brand is now he's a public
intellectual quite frankly I think it
was is what Tucker Carlson said now what
do we mean by a public intellectual many
of us can imagine sort of like the
academic intellectual right this is
someone who and I'm this is this is the
caricature and I understand I'm playing
into the caricature but the idea would
be the academic intellectual is someone
who if you put a camera in front of them
for a TV show they're not really good at
explaining their ideas and they're not
concise and they go on and on and they
talk about their work and their thoughts
in a way that is not relatable to the
average person and they are sometimes
seen as as uh
um maybe Elite or condescending to the
average person right so public
intellectual would be it's someone who
is well known and an intelligent you
know learned person from an academic uh
a pedigree of sorts but who is also
contributing their knowledge in the sort
of more popular culture I guess we would
say and is recognized both on the
academic side but also on the
non-academic and sort of like media side
and by members of society in general so
obviously by that definition Russell
Brand is not a public intellectual but
the bigger story here for me is I've
said before you know sometimes Marjorie
Taylor green will rant somewhere and I
will say to you all
a lot a lot of the American right wing
sees her as a thinking person
and Lauren bobert will rant or you know
Ted Cruz will make some statement about
a legal precedent during a hearing and I
will say there are a lot of people in
the U.S on the right who see that as
what it means to be a thinker and of
course Russell Brand is very far from
really what I would consider to be
public intellectuals now public
intellectuals today do look and sound a
lot different than at times past so I'll
give you some examples of people that I
do think are sort of public
intellectuals one that comes to mind and
I was just recent listening to some of
his podcasts and and that's why he's on
my mind
Cal Newport Cal Newport is a PhD
computer scientist who teaches at
Georgetown he's been on the show before
who writes both for academic audiences
and for General audiences about the
socio-cultural impacts of Technology
uh and and so many other things he's
written articles that would be really
for an academic audience and he's also
written great popular books like deep
work and a world without email and
others that to me makes a lot more sense
as like a modern public intellectual and
when you when you listen to Cal's
podcast you realize wow this is a very
different thing than Russell Brand
Cal doesn't have a British accent I will
mention that other examples maybe Jared
Diamond someone who
has done a ton of academic work and and
really deep field work and also has
written books uh for popular consumption
this one I I'm less sure but someone
like kazuo ishiguro the British Japanese
British writer uh Salman Rushdie comes
to mind
um Camille Paglia even if you don't like
her views hard to argue that that's not
you know when we talk about a public
intellectual today that's what we're
talking about Daniel Dennett would be
another example so anyway it's an
interesting thing I don't know if Tucker
is is serious when he says Russell Brand
is a public intellectual or not
um but it's a very interesting phrase to
hear amuse particularly when the right
has spent a long time sort of deriding
the value of public intellectuals until
they found someone they can try to pass
off as one in order to try to make some
kind of political Point interesting an
interesting uh use of that term imagine
for a second that you try logging into
your email account only to find that
your your password was changed an hour
ago and then you get notifications of
activity from your bank and then your
credit cards that is what identity theft
is like and it's a horrible feeling and
we dealt with it at the show not that
long ago but now I have an app called
Aura which gives me much more peace of
mind our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices go to aura.com Pacman to try it
free for seven day is your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below